for us the vision
is to change the mindset of humankind
to make people understand that no matter
what they are going through
it's okay and they can speak with other
people they can meet other people that
are going through the same life event
and they can gain relief
super fast and i think that the the
vision for us is to restructure humanity
in a way of small circles
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about mental health
meet erad
the founder and ceo of circles
erad eichler lives in kibbutz married
plus 4 and is a serial entrepreneur was
announced by the world economic forum as
a social entrepreneur of the year he is
the winner of the bagilan university
social leadership award and social
impact hero by media magazine
he is the founder and chairperson of
shakulotov israeli leading organization
for vocational recovery founder of
circles an online platform for copying
circles in life crises and founder of
israeli social business school israeli
third age festival and he is a podcaster
irad i am honored to have you here
welcome
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thank you so much for
having me super excited to be here i
came across an article at forbes and
that would talk about circles and talked
about the work that you're doing and and
i read through it and i was like wow i
cannot believe you know that that first
i'm so happy that somebody's doing it
second i can't believe that it hasn't
been done already and there aren't
enough solutions out there and this
crazy problem that you're solving which
really anybody know everybody in the
world faces regardless of race gender
ethnicity age whatever it may be
and and i'm excited to dive deep with
you i'm also honored to be a very very
small part of the journey and so thank
you for allowing me to do that but over
the next 20 minutes i am gonna just
bombard you with some questions so you
got tell me a little bit about your own
story and and how you end up starting
circles
yeah yeah i think i that totally
resonates the kind of like the opening
because
there's like a huge huge huge uh
challenge uh that humankind is facing
and i think it's it's it's the same as
the uh kind of mental health challenge
it's pretty much the same as the
environmental
challenge and we'll talk about it but in
terms of my myself i've been building
businesses that solve social problems
for the last 20 years my previous
venture was uh
integrating people with disabilities in
the community and specifically in the
job market and
while i was building this uh this
organization uh
i my mother had cancer and i witnessed
her
fighting cancer
during it was seven years and in the
last few months um
i spent a lot of time with her and i saw
how lonely is the experience of being a
cancer patient my my mother was a
principal at the high school so she led
high school and she has like she was
super you know uh uh um present woman
she was super uh enthusiastic she has a
lot of kind of like uh she was like the
educational woman that you can imagine
like really a leader and then within one
day her identity changed and she became
a cancer patient from a super successful
woman
to uh a cancer patient and that brought
a lot of loneliness to her life and even
though i was with her uh she told me
that you know
i'm still feeling lonely you don't
really get what i'm going through and
then
two two days after i overheard of
speaking with another with a friend of
hers that had cancer as well and then my
mother was vivid and alive and i felt
the connection there and that struck me
like the difference between the con
between the two conversations
and yeah and then after she passed away
i was dealing with grief and it was uh
it was also a lonely experience and i
went to therapy i've been to therapy
before and it was super helpful because
it was about my relationship with my
parents and with my
spouse and my children and being a
father and so on it was really helpful
and then
when my mother passed away i went to
therapy
and then it's kind of like it wasn't
it was really frustrating being in
therapy because i wanted to speak about
my grief and about my mother and kind of
like wanted to experience kind of like
what other people are experiencing i
wanted to talk about my grief and it
wasn't it wasn't the right setting and
then
i kind of zoomed out and looked at this
industry and kind of and i was looking
for a for a go-to place as yourself i
was struck like
that in such a connected world in a way
there people are so lonely and there
isn't a go-to place for people to
connect in a meaningful way and to have
a meaningful conversation even when i'm
saying that i'm saying it's unbelievable
that this this this uh it doesn't exist
but it doesn't and that's what we are
building at circles that's kind of the
the essence of what we are building we
are connecting people into super small
groups in a meaningful way we are taking
a bunch of strangers and make them uh
bond and connect between them and i have
i don't know if we we don't have enough
time for a lot of stories about our
members but i can tell you just
one one yeah before you go before you go
into a member story because i think that
it'll make a very big impact
just as it did on me and and i've been
i've been following for a while and i
think that
what's really interesting here is to
understand the perspective of how big
the problem is you're mentioning you
know your own personal example and but
obviously everybody deals with grief and
everybody deals with with with issues
you know let's just even take the united
and has it st changing at all in recent
years
yeah so i think if you look kind of like
let's look at trends so first of all the
first trend that we we need to mention
is trent the trend of moving to the city
which is kind of been in the last two
years but it broke down all the support
system that we had in the villages and
communities that we lived in and then
another trend that came
that kicked in is technology and
most people talk about kind of like the
online versus the offline and how
offline is really meaningful as opposed
to offline and i think that there's a
point there but i think the most
important thing to understand is it's
not the offline versus the online it's
the synchronic
versus the unsynchronic real time
so we could have had this conversation
you know
you could have i don't know sent me
questions i could have recorded but
us
spending time right now together and me
talking you nodding and vice versa
that's real human connection and that's
the real thing and that's what kind of
like social media did to us it's kind of
flattened
our relation our the relationship
between people and that that made uh um
kind of like the epidemic of loneliness
grow and with it mental health uh
challenges that every one of us is
experiencing have one of my friends just
had recently a birthday i was the only
one that called him everybody texted him
but it's i was the only one that
literally spoke with him and that's
really it really makes a difference like
that's real human connection so uh and
when you look at mental health like and
you see the peak because of covet 19 but
also because of the all of the trends
that i mentioned but it's also related
to the solutions that are out there in
the last 100 120 years the only solution
that was out there is therapy and
therapy it's kind of it's it's it's
there's like it's super effective in one
way but it's effective in 20 of the
cases to 20 of the people because it's
not accessible in in in pricing wise uh
it's not accessible stigma wise it's not
it's not relevant to to a lot of the the
things that we are going in life so 80
of the people 80 of the time need a
different solution and there aren't any
out there and that's kind of that's how
the the big is the problem and we look
at for the example that the u.s market
and you think of all the caregivers
people that are taking care of their
elderly parents of people that are
taking care of the special needs kid 40
million people in the states are our
caregivers if you're looking at
the the loanings towards the holiday 11
of the americans
are saying that they will
experience extreme loneliness that's 37
million people 70 percent of americans
saying that they they
care about their families and friends
dealing with loneliness during the
holidays you know you have uh
the diversity you have
1.5
divorces 1.5 million of course divorces
every year in the states
like
double it and then multiply it by five
because that's kind of like the time
that it takes to so it's like it's
unbelie 20 of the population are people
with special needs every people with
special needs at least three people that
it influenced their life and one percent
of the people on the population are
people with mental health
five five people will be kind of
affected by uh and so on and so forth so
it's it's it's all of their life and i'm
talking about people that are
women that are giving birth and so like
i have so many examples but at the end
of the day we need more mental health
solutions out there and not just therapy
i think that you know first of all it's
very impressive that you know all these
statistics
and and there are there were a lot of
them so so it's very impressive on one
hand it's very disturbing on the other
hand obviously and i think that what
really you know is is making me think is
that is the fact that this is you know
the the the ways we grieve and the
reasons why we believe they they go they
span across they meet every single
person regardless of how rich or poor
you are where you grew up where where
you went to school it doesn't even
matter we're all being struck by these
moments where we need assistance and
there just aren't good solutions so
before we even dive into circles and
what you're doing there
you know from your point of view having
thought about this field for a while
how can we help people at scale in the
most ideal way possible deal with grief
like this what is an optimal solution
here
so uh there are two kind of like there
is the the essence of talking about
things i think the most important thing
mindset wise is for people to understand
that if you talk about something it
brings relief that's kind of like the
essential basic of of of
feeling better there's like and i think
social media kind of like as opposed to
it's counterintuitive but social media
looks like we are sharing a lot of
things at the end of the day what we are
sharing are the successes that leads
people to leads people to kind of like
uh uh you know to feelings
the siloed feel feel lonely so that's
the first thing and this and the second
thing and that leads us to to circles i
strongly believe that being part of a
group
is super important for people's uh
mental health and i live in a kibbutz
it's a small group uh or it's a big
group uh uh you know we have 500 people
oh but we are kind of like we know each
other and we are kind of like we are
taking responsibility together about our
life in in various ways but
me being part of this community
really supports my mental health and i
think that people should be part of
groups and and and basically that's what
we are building and just kind of like to
the the key key uh uh important things
about groups so first of all
if you're part of a group
you don't feel lonely you're kind of
like there is a sense of belonging so
and the belonging is the opposite of
loneliness so that's the first secondly
being part of the group you feel normal
because you feel that people kind of
like like you are
going through the same thing as you are
it makes you feel normal the third part
is that you get to help other people
it's not just getting help is really
it's people need to do need to get help
but getting help is one thing but
providing help that's really empowering
and when you're part of the group of a
group you you help other people and the
fourth part which is kind of like it's
not obvious but it's really a meaningful
mental in terms of mental health when
you are part of a group you don't talk
about your life you actually live your
life within a group there's a lot of you
when you're part of the group there's a
lot of interactions between the group
members there's a lot of feelings
there's a lot of feedback there's a lot
of things going on which is literally
life uh uh and that's what kind of like
groups uh uh bring us and being part of
the group that's really uh reliefing and
and and brings a lot of uh uh you know
goodness to people's life
right
now
if you're looking at you know circles
and what you're doing there with the
product how are you integrating this
idea of groups and meaningful
and you know meaningful group support to
empower mental health especially you
know for those that are that are going
through some struggle how are you
actually implementing that as a
technological product
yeah so so first of all i i want to kind
of like just to frame what is the group
okay group because
uh facebook kind of hijacked a lot of of
basic terms in our life group
friends uh which is not pretty it's like
when i say group i mean
a group of people that know each other
that have a meaningful relationship
between them they they have kind of like
a there is a set of rules for the group
there's a bonding so that's kind of
that's that the basic group and
the the the
most challenging thing when you look at
a group is to build the group to form
the group because you need to find the
right people for the group in order
that all members will get uh will
benefit from being part of the group and
uh and that's what kind of like we
leverage technology because we
we
first of all we use technology to find
the right group for people we collect
data that people are sharing and we kind
of like and we help them find the right
group for them
we use technology to reach a lot of like
a broader audience because everything is
online you can reach broader audience
and then you can do a much more
effective
much more effective
matching
and so that's one algorithm that we are
building the other part of the groups is
is when you look at a group there are
three main components so i talked about
the members like finding the right
members having a small group of six to
eight people
another component is the group
facilitators and as opposed to uh their
name not all of group facilitators know
how to facilitate group they kind of
like they know what they learn but it's
not an ongoing learning so which what we
are doing is we are kind of like
leveraging technology technology to
collect the formal and informal and
knowledge about group facilitation and
help them be the best facilitator they
can be i can give just one example to
give us a a great a great uh
best practice is to say the name of the
members of the group in the first 10
minutes so people can feel that they
were hurt
so we are listening to the conversation
and we kind of help the group
facilitator remember which one of the
group members they mention and we help
them kind of like monitor uh the dynamic
and and there are many examples
and the third part so we said we talked
about group members we talked about
group uh uh facilitators and their tools
and of course the professional tools i
won't go into all the features but in in
essence we are kind of making them the
best facilitator and the third part is
the structure of the group the setting
super important
for everything that like your the
structure of your uh podcast is that you
have 20 minutes right it's a structure
and that keeps that's kind of like
it frames the conversation as opposed to
two hours right
so
we are structuring groups so we have uh
off session and off session we have
methods for the session and we have
method for getting people to form the
group getting people to know each other
there's stages on the group so you with
technology to make each part of of it
easy think about for one example uh
is that when you go into the on the
first time that you go into a meeting
room for of people could be your first
day job at your work or whatever it's
really hard to speak right like what
will people think of me it's really like
getting into a group it's a it's a big
challenge if you're even if you're super
confident 100
we take a lot of friction because we
build the onboarding for the members in
a in a in a fl
seamless way but they are getting all
the information that they need about the
process about the meeting about the
group members uh and that kind of takes
a lot of pressure and a lot of stress
down and it helps them join uh
the meetings now i think that one you
know intuitive thing that a lot of
people would have difficulty with is
this they thought okay if i'm grieving
something
i'm gonna go now online and meet a bunch
of people that i didn't don't really
know and i've never really met and
they're they also happen to be
geographically in different locations
and they're gonna look different from me
they're gonna speak different from the
way that i speak
am i going to be able to share
and to be exposed in an intimate way
which i assume that these groups require
well what have you been finding as
you've been facilitating already many
groups like this
so i think yeah that's kind of like the
most challenging thing for people it's
kind of like to to
to to join groups so we found that first
of all
if you get to learn about the group
beforehand about who the members are
what they are dealing with it really
takes a lot of stress down if you find
the right group for the people so it's
not just grief group grief group is too
general like uh someone that lost their
spouse and someone that lost their child
it's not the same
group so we have for example a user
a member she lost both her grandson and
her
spouse she joined two groups
two grief groups but different groups
right because wow losing a grandson it's
totally different than losing a spouse
and the connection that she has on one
group are not not the same connection as
she has
on the other group and that's
that's where kind of like we we
kind of like geared towards building
super super specific groups for super
specific needs because we
know that it makes a difference for the
people we want to have people the
feeling that they're kind of like met
their
lost friends in a way like their their
other selves like people that experience
the same thing having said that you need
to to to have different characters in
the group right you don't want everybody
to be extravagant in the group because
and everybody like me will take over the
conversation right now and uh you want
you want to have balance
right
where where's what's the vision here so
you have a beautiful product that people
are using and you're you're they're
joining groups and there's going to be
some exciting things for for the holiday
with the loneliness pandemic but
what's you know where where is circles
in two three five years
so for us the vision
is to change the mindset of humankind
to make people understand that no matter
what they are going through
it's okay and they can speak with other
people they can meet other people that
are going through the same life event
and they can gain relief
super fast and i think the the vision
for us is to restructure humanity in a
way of small circles that's that's
that's the vision because
on our modern life we have different
identities right i'm a parent and i'm
also a businessman and i'm also a
partner and i also i'm also assigned for
each one of those identities i have
different challenges and different
things that i'm dealing with and the
only one that the only people that will
understand me are people that are going
through the same so the way we envision
the world is each one of us will be part
of at least one circle dealing with
anything that you are dealing with and
by the way it doesn't have to be the
specific circles that we we see now on
the website it will be different circles
in different structures the structure
will be different we will have a setting
for intensive circle we will have a
setting for super light circle and so on
so it's like at the end of the day just
what's important for us is the sense of
belonging we want to people to have the
sense of belonging and and we won't stop
until we kind of like get to the last
man on earth or woman that are dealing
with loneliness and kind of like connect
them to other people
sounds easy
of course none
but it sounds like a a problem that uh i
think that anybody would be incredibly
proud to wake up every day knowing that
that's where
that's where they're headed one of the
questions that i enjoy asking the show
is you know where do you gather your
inspiration from on a daily basis i i
don't think that question needs to be
asked here and i think that you know
just me sitting here i'm getting
inspired and
and and i can definitely see you know
how
people working with you and yourself
that you know getting that passion
and that that intrinsic motivation to
push forward and just like the story
that you mentioned about about this
woman with her grandson and her spouse
and i'm sure there are other so many
other stores that you're aware of that
your colleagues are aware of that are
literally changing lives and and so
thank you for the amazing work but i do
have one last short question for you
which is if i would ask any of your
co-founders colleagues and people that
really know you well who who is who who
are you
who is iran so what are a few words that
you would use to describe yourself
wow
that's a that's an amazing question
because i think i'm changing all of the
time so yeah i think it's kind of like
uh uh i i want i want kind of like get
away from the question i will answer the
question i'm just saying that i think
that i'm changing but i think the the
kind of like the common uh
like the the basic thing that i
i really want to be and i think i'm
doing pretty uh um
good job in doing it is being informal
and understanding kind of like the i
i understand
that i'm not
uh uh what i'm doing there's a there's
like i'm not confused but what by my
role my position my
you know my my kind of like i'm at the
end of the day every person on the every
colleague every partner every uh team
member i think that uh they know that uh
i i
respect their opinion and then as i
respect myself so it's kind of like
in in in the same way so i think that's
something that
so what what so what are the few words
that you would describe yourself how how
would you
yeah again i guess in for informal so
i'll tell you a story yesterday i i
spoke to
the idc students here in israel and uh
and uh and one of my team members told
me listen yeah it was in in a in a in a
different like you know another
company's offices and she told me the
the ceo's there is really like you uh
and i went there and i kind of like met
him turned out i met the wrong guy but
uh there are two ceos in this company
and and he was informal so i was i told
her yeah i'm yeah i get it i know what
you said so i think that's kind of like
the i think that's
a lot
yeah
the informal and kind of like uh super
kind of like i think transparent uh
and
and and kind of like
trying
to uh um to lead by example meaning that
i i i'm practicing what i'm preaching
i love it
thank you very very much this was
interesting and inspiring and and and i
loved every minute of it and best of
luck with circles i'm really excited to
see where you take this and then and the
impact that you're going to have in the
world so thank you very very much
thanks so much for having me it was so
much fun
[Music]